welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss here with Tommy bechtold hello
Tommy Eric good to see you wow it's so
worth getting up early in the morning
for this kind of news baby that's right
there's a new Ahsoka trailer and then
three new Star Wars films were just
announced including Daisy Ridley
returning as Rey all this and more
announced that Star Wars celebration in
London and we're gonna react to the
Ahsoka trailer we're gonna break down
all the big news everything you need to
know all the big highlights all the big
headlines coming out of this celebration
lucasfilm panel it's an interesting time
to be back in Star Wars they're really
filling out the map and Tommy and I got
you covered we're gonna take you from
bb-8 to Zeb it is early Tommy and I are
waking up to this uh news and I love
waking up to Star Wars with Tommy this
has been the favorite my favorite part
of my job the only thing that would have
been better is if when I turned over in
my bed this morning you were just
smiling at me and saying it's Star Wars
day baby I can't be by your bed if I am
every voice
all right let's take a look at this
Ahsoka trailer I'm very excited to react
to it with you Tommy you ready let's go
something's coming
something dark
oh
this is like
that is awesome
I'm hooked I'm in I'm ready nobody
nobody utilizes lightsabers like her oh
hello Cat Sabine with the long hair yeah
whoa
whose voice is that Ohara
oh okay my boy Ray Stevenson
yeah let's play bailing I think is his
name
this music is so good yeah
it's been a while
things have changed it's like they're
back on that same platform as they were
in the rebels fanatics
that is there he's not turning around no
air to the end show us his face
Stevenson looks like a ripped George
Clooney
he looks great yeah the Jedi fell a long
time ago
what color would you say that is
that's that's like orange because this
other one is red
[Music]
Perhaps it is time to begin again
Count Me In Baby
I Love It
wow wow wow
holy smokes
I I'm such a baby though I just wanted
to throw on face reveal so bad I was
like come on I know how are they keeping
this a secret at this point like they
they have an actor on set and he's got a
blue face he's not just a stand-in actor
I mean they're lucasfilm is really good
at keeping these secrets I think I'm
very impressed that was a great trailer
though you're right the music is so
intense for it the lightsaber in battles
look like we're gonna have this might be
the premiere lightsaber battling Disney
Plus show that we're gonna get even
though there was an Obi-Wan show I think
yeah it just everything looked so good I
mean they're really oh my God yeah sign
me up sign me up I'm a simp I'm a SIM
for the Star Wars baby you know I going
into this week I thought they were going
to have a Bryce Dallas Howard episode of
the Mandalorian to kind of set up to tee
up what they've been announcing two days
later at uh at Celebration but now it
kind of seems like just get this episode
out and then no one will be talking
about it two days later uh at the Star
Wars celebration because now like I
think a lot of us were a little worried
coming out of that last episode like man
maybe Lauren really better stick the
landing and Ahsoka you know Mandalorian
has been the flagship show for Disney
plus as a platform and they really need
to make sure that like people are in are
on board for this era but I I think this
show Ahsoka has calmed a lot of those
fears yeah we got a lot to talk about
um okay so what do we know about Ahsoka
it's coming August 2023. so we'll see it
this year this summer not that far away
guys in in uh content terms that's one
secret Invasion and one Guardians of the
Galaxy movie right it's under there we
could do that in our sleep the uh the
cast is it's going to be like a
live-action Star Wars Rebel so we're all
gonna need to like look back re-watch do
another primer on Rebels caught up but
it's gonna be picking up after the
events of the rebels finale where Ahsoka
and Sabine Wren were teaming up in the
search for Ezra Bridger uh and Ezra
Richard's gonna be played in the show by
Iman espandi Mary Elizabeth Winstead's
gonna be playing Captain Harrison Doula
the captain of the ghost uh and then
Natasha Lou bordizo is gonna be playing
Sabine Wren Choppers going to show up
and we just saw Zeb in live action yes
that's even Bloom voicing him on a
recent episode of the Mandalorian now
interesting casting here we don't know
about Grand admiral thrawn yet but in
this trailer they gave a little wink
where they called him the heir to the
Empire which is just perfect Timothy
zahn's novels and that those were really
in my opinion the best of the Star Wars
expanded universe novels with I mean
these are the ones that like made them
essential reading for a lot of people in
the early 90s and really the character
of thrawn was the was the face of it
it's just such a fascinating character
obviously filoni gets that that's why he
brought him into Star Wars Rebels and
that's why he's now bringing them into
live action I have a question for Eric
based on the timing of this and the
ships that we saw is there a chance we
see Laura Dern's character because she's
still alive now right and she was well
Captain hold of from uh from The Last
Jedi we saw those ships resistance
transport ships and then they cut to mon
mothma which I guess at this point would
just be Republic transport ships so I'm
wondering if we could get a Laura Dern
Cameo uh very very very possible I mean
uh at pretty much all the key players
who were there at the start of the force
awakens on the uh on the new Republic
side on the resistance Fleet side could
all be key players in this I think
they're going to tie into the movie that
this leads up to yes I think it's more
like we see Laura during there but hey
Laura Jordan's not afraid of doing
streaming shows up and everything on HBO
everything Mike White does yeah I'm
yearning for a darning you know
uh now um other things we know about
this show Ray Stevenson's gonna be
playing some other kind of villainous
character he's an admiral and his name
from what we could tell is Balin maybe
Balin skull and uh he did do the voice
of gar Saxon you know um that that
Mandalorian usurper of uh of of of
Cronus that was being Ran's home moon
but yeah now he's gonna I like how they
brought him in to play another character
and he looks incredible in this his
lightsaber what color would you call
that I call it like a red orange yeah it
reminds me of the Popsicles you would
eat in the summer that came in like
purple red and then the orange was
always kind of bled into the red The
Good Humor popsicles I'm gonna call it a
good humor orange we got uh Ivana sakno
is playing a character and I believe her
name is shin maybe Shin Haiti and just
worth noting out if those are the names
of them uh skill in Haiti are the names
of two wolves that chase the sun in Moon
and Norse mythology so it's kind of cool
cool naming conventions that they're
working in there there might be multiple
seasons of the show during the panel
Rosario Dawson said that if it does well
they could do a second season um but
yeah Rosario doesn't be quote looking
for someone that someone's probably
going to be Ezra Bridger but during this
time period uh mon mothma Genevieve
O'Reilly previously seen in Andor she is
still alive in this new Republic era you
know she's a um the first Chancellor of
the new Republic but running into
probably a lot of the same political
drama that she ran into on on and or
potentially more frustrating I was gonna
say at this point she's got to be like
what else can we do what else can we do
to just create a free Society uh without
uh despotic rulers but you know what you
can't because guess what guess what's
breathing down the back your neck the
first order so I mean I'm going to be
breaking down this trailer frame by
frame I think our trailer breakdown will
be able to come out on Sunday on the new
rock stars channel so keep an eye out
for that I'm really excited for this
show I think it looks incredible I'm a
big fan of being my best self and Beyond
filling my brain with fun things
bugs wearing pants hamsters and top hats
you know the usual stuff I also like to
take care of my body and if you like
taking care of your body you're going to
want to fully tune in because we are
going to have one of the best offers
we've ever given on this channel thanks
to geology geology is an 18-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology creates simple and effective
skin care and Hair Care routines
customized just for you with ingredients
that are proven to work their products
are built around just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
with ingredients that are dermatologist
tested proven to work and personalized
to your needs geology has got you
covered no matter how you're looking to
up your personal care game but right now
they're offering a special offer for a
skin care sampler pack which is great
because their skin care stuff rules
geology's line of skincare products can
help you fight acne reduce oil-ness
prevent wrinkles and combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging
personally I'm a fan of their vitamin C
plus if you uric acid serum but I use
everything else geology has co-wash for
your hair body wash for your body and
deodorant for your odors whatever you
need gelji has you covered there's never
been a better time to try geology than
right now for a limited time to use code
new Rockstar's 100 to get 100 off your
personalized 30 day skincare sample set
all you have to do is cover the 495 for
shipping this is hands down the best
deal that is out there and on top of
that new Rockstar's fans get an
exclusive bonus offer up to 50 off on
additional skin hair and body product of
your choice when you add it to your
trial click the link in the description
or go to
geolog.i.e rockstars 100 to get started
okay important announcements we for
years have been waiting for Star Wars to
announce what their next movies are
going to be and now we finally know they
are going to be doing three movies so
the first one we should talk about is
going to be one starring Daisy Ridley as
Rey it's going to be taking place 15
years after the rise of Skywalker yes
and it's going to show Ray's attempt to
rebuild the Jedi Order
um and it's going to be directed by
Charmin obayi chenoy who directed Two
episodes of Ms Marvel for Disney plus uh
and it's an accomplished Canadian
Pakistani film filmmaker and it's
written by Stephen Knight so that's
super exciting I mean now this makes
more sense why they're sticking to
Galaxy's Edge being this particular era
yeah the two and in the SQL era because
they still have plans to build this out
and I'm happy to see JC Ridley back I
think she's a really great actor I agree
and I think you know however however the
the sequels land with you that character
lands with pretty much all Star Wars
fans as a protagonist certainly with me
and you Eric you know I love looking
back I love the fact that with shows
like Mandalorian and Obi-Wan we've been
able to go back and book a Boba Fett and
like fill in some gaps Rogue one an
incredible film that fills in some gaps
but I do think you know not to invoke
WWE but it's like their their beginning
of their shows always start with then
now forever It's like Star Wars needs to
be treated with then now forever type of
of story World building it's like we do
need to keep moving forward in it for it
to continue and for a new fan ends I
think to grasp and be interested in
moving along with it because a lot of
these shows and movies that come out
that fill in the gaps are for the
established fans right the huge there's
a huge fan base it's certainly going to
be profitable but if you want the like
the new generation of five to ten
through 10 year olds to like fall in
love with Star Wars you got to introduce
new characters there's got to be fresh
fresh material coming out for them so I
think the the introduction of these
three movies the other two we're going
to talk to in a second brilliant I think
it's a brilliant way to stagger them in
three such specific different time
periods uh with different filmmakers I'm
I'm excited let's let's keep going let's
keep going and you know worth noting out
that grogu may still be alive 15 years
after the rise of Skywalker he would be
91 years old at that time maybe but it's
a nine years short of when uh Yoda in
his lifetime became a Jedi master so at
this point grogu may be talking he may
be a moody teenager I had to pitch in
Indy Rockstar's video recently that girl
who should never talk he could just be a
stoic his entire life but just get
slightly older slightly wiser but never
needs to talk but uh the second movie
that Tommy alluded to is going to be a
Mandalorian era movie directed by Dave
filoni finally giving Dave filoni the
proper gig the real Star Wars treatment
of directing one of these movies
um it's going to be taking place between
Return of the Jedi and the force awakens
the same era as the Mandalorian book of
Boba Fett and Ahsoka and it's gonna be
the culmination of all those story lines
uh that kind of sets us right into the
force awakens so all these other
storylines they now have a destination
point and it's going to be this
Mandalorian era movie directed by Dave
filoni and I I feel like the villain of
this movie is going to be grand Admiral
got to be if they can stick to landing
on this if I could spend the next 30
years of my life re-watching all of
those shows and then capping it off with
this film I mean I'll I don't know I'll
just uh
oh thank the maker I'll thank the maker
every day of my life for it I mean they
could just call that movie thrawn yeah
and it'll make a billion dollars yes I
mean and it literally will make a
billion dollars the third movie we
should talk about is gonna be directed
by James Mangold uh he's the amazing
director who is currently working on
Indiana Jones five the in the dial of
Destiny uh and he's directed he directed
Logan and he directed The Wolverine
Leopold Caden Leopold one of the best
rom-coms of the eyes come on guys
amazing film so just be clear the
acolyte it's gonna be said during the
high Republic before that you have the
Old Republic and leading into that era
will be the dawn of the Jedi that's the
movie that James Mangold is directing I
just want to see the first time a Jedi
picks up a kyber crystal and then goes I
can make a sword out of this
just pile after pile of Jedi on uh on
illum just with her eyes poked out from
Crystal blades and one of them is like
oh I pointed away from my ears got it so
we got this glorious timeline of all the
Star Wars eras starting with Dawn of the
Jedi that's going to be James mangold's
film then you have the Old Republic
that's when like Knights of the Old
Republic took place then you have the
high Republic that's when the acolyte
takes place and then the fall of the
Jedi that's Order 66 that's during the
prequel era you have uh the reign of the
Empire that's the Galactic Civil War
during the original trilogy and during
uh bad batch in Andor and then you have
age of the Rebellion that's also the
original trilogy uh A New Hope Empire
Strikes Back in Return of the Jedi you
have the new Republic that we're now
seeing on the Mandalorian in the book of
Boba Fett we have the rise of the first
order that's gonna be on the tail end of
this era that leads into the force
awakens and the sequel Trilogy and then
on the other side of that you'll have
this new Jedi Order that will be the new
Rey film but will they learn their
lesson God I hope not because I want
these movies to continue forever I want
I want a history doomed to repeat itself
learn nothing I want another like I want
another Jedi and jet and Rey's new like
Jedi Academy to be like I'm feeling
pulled towards the dark side and for her
to be like it's probably nothing it's
nothing
so let's recap some of the other big
headlines we heard starting with the
acolyte so the acolyte apparently people
at Star Wars celebration were shown a
little teaser of it and we we didn't get
to see it there's a bunch of BS but uh
this can be set during the high Republic
ERA this will be the earliest in Star
Wars chronology that we've ever been in
live action uh we're gonna see the
height really of Jedi arrogance says it
sounds like they're going to be
investigating some Sith conspiracy but
showrunner Leslie Headland said it's
going to follow the perspective of the
villains and she used this phrase that
makes no sense to me but it's Frozen
meets Kill Bill it makes enough sense to
me baby
I've always said if Anna would have
taken some katana swords to cut off uh
that one that all awful Prince that
tried to marry her rather than just
sending him off on a boat things would
have been much better but unfortunately
she didn't she let Him Live Well it's
interesting she says quote the bad guys
are going to be the underdogs in this so
it sounds like the the Jedi might be the
antagonists in this okay
um and she said it's inspired by Akira
kurosawa's Hidden Fortress which is
interesting that she's going back
because I feel like that was a huge
inspiration for George Lucas and the
first Star Wars film in fact the
Imperial logo the Imperial Crest comes
from kurosawa's Hidden Fortress so it's
gonna be starting Amanda Stenberg and
Daphne Keane and then Carrie Anne Moss
is gonna have a role Manny Jacinto from
the good place gonna have a role Lee
jong-jae from squid games he's gonna be
starring as a Jedi master junis uh
suhotamo is gonna be playing uh a Wookie
Jedi Master which is gonna be great all
these little details that they've
announced are so exciting for these
projects yeah I'm hoping they say Kill
Bill meets Frozen I when I first started
reading plot descriptions of the shows
like this kind of sounds like True
Detective yeah like the cops are crooked
but they're they're investigating some
creepy Mystic uh Supernatural mystery
like that's that's what I'm hoping from
the show yeah I mean it's Disney plus
but it'd be nice to see some like people
like force corpsed against the wall with
like some like violent deaths I don't
know how I mean listen we saw Darth
Vader snap a neck and Kenobi so I feel
like all bets are off so it's gonna be
coming in 2024. four episodes I've
apparently finished and then in this
trailer footage there was just a lot of
great martial arts and lightsaber action
uh including a yellow lightsaber which
is very interesting yes gonna be an
interesting show
um we also learned a lot about the
Skeleton Crew so this is John Watts uh
show that's gonna be kind of like an
amblin kids Adventure Kids lost in space
with Jude Law
um so filoni describes a story about a
group of kids in the Star Wars Galaxy go
on an adventure more than they can
handle Jude Law's character is a Jedi
it's gonna be interesting I you know
have they established before that he was
a good guy because in my mind the whole
time since the announcement of his
character I'm like he's gonna be the bad
guy of the show when they initially
announced him I was like oh maybe Jude
Law will be thrawn but no he's gonna be
a Jedi who kind of is like the the
caretaker he's the sloth of the of The
Goonies Dynamic lightsaber
thank you
guys
yeah and we had to escape a cave by
running under Jude Law's legs yes as he
holds a boulder on his shoulder
um sloth love love Max repo uh all right
sorry speaking of Max repo one of the
kids in this group is going to be a
nortolin Max revo's race you can see set
photos of this kid and they don't show
the finished VFX yet but it's just one
of the kids has to wear one of these
vocab suits but still wears overall so
it's just gonna be his head that gets
Eric are they making this show for us it
kind of feels like they're making the
show for us a little one of those kids
is just a chunk it's wonderful
I hope he tells an elaborate lie about
the worst thing he ever did and then
ever in the audience was like
[Music]
hmm
so the show's currently opposed
production uh and uh the other kids uh
let's see Carrie condon's gonna be
playing a role in it uh Ravi Kevin
Conyers uh kiriana crater and Robert
Timothy Smith are the actors uh John
Watts is gonna be directing some of the
episodes the Daniels recently October
winning directors yes of everything
everyone at once they're gonna be
directing some of this uh Bryce Dallas
Howard's directing some of this Jake
schreier David Lowry Lee Isaac Chung I
am so excited for David Lowry's episode
because his filmography is so eccentric
he's such an interesting filmmaker Green
Knight is such a Trippy film ghost story
was such an interesting premise and then
Pete's Dragon is freaking Pete's Dragon
so like you know good for him
um we got a little update uh from the
Mandalorian Rick family as we knew is
directing the final two episodes some
footage was shown apparently attendees
of Star Wars celebration either are
currently or will be seen episode seven
tonight oh uh so look out for spoilers
and social media I'm sure people will be
talking about it
um but according to the footage shown at
Celebration MAF Gideon is going to
return I think as we all expected he
would after last week's episode of the
Mandalorian we also got an update on
Andor so and or season two is currently
in production it they're scheduled to
finish production in August it sounds
like and Tony Gilroy expected a year of
post-production so some people are
expected in August of next year of 2024
could be the next uh 12 episodes of
Andor and we learned that the whole
scene of I can't swim from narkina five
was the last thing they shot for season
one which is very interesting to me
because it sounds like uh 80 circus
might come back for season two oh this
character might have survived that I
can't swim I can't swim incredible just
just incredible uh Tommy and I were
recently at WonderCon and we met these
two awesome members of the I think they
were part of the 500 first group their
cosplay was incredible they were playing
lifeguards the narkina five prison
uniform but they were also lifeguards
just the guys who had they been there
yeah
yes those guys were awesome shout out to
them for sure they were great
um we're actually doing a lot more Live
Events this summer uh and so we've got a
big announcement coming soon baby I
cannot wait we can't wait to hang out
with you guys I think that uh are all
the big headlines unless I'm mistaken uh
there was also a trailer shown for
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
very exciting it's it's an interesting
time to be back it's just nice to have
some movies to look forward to some live
action films because those are the ones
that really bring everyone together and
one of them is going to force everyone
to watch every single freaking episode
of The Book of Boba Fett and I love that
you know I know you're watching I know
you're out there watching I can feel the
eyes
watching us on Wookie leaks watching old
episodes I felt something I haven't felt
in such a long time a stirring inside me
the book of Boba Fett Wikileaks have
become relevant to game we thank you so
much for watching subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive I got my analysis
of Christopher Nolan's the interstellar
that's a must watch for me baby I gotta
say it's my one of my favorite movies of
all time uh I will be watching Eric's
Deep dive of interstellar like this the
whole time
it's gonna be a weepy one that's my
impression of Matthew McConaughey
uh so you can support our growing
Network by grabbing something from our
merch store nerdright.shop subscribe to
new rockstars on YouTube all social
platforms follow Tommy italyback told
follow me at eavos we'll see you uh in a
few days for uh Wookie leaks for um a
book of Boba Fett no for the Mandalorian
chapter 23.
chapter seven either way I think you
gotta read just re-watch it yep all
right thank you for watching everyone
bye-bye bye
[Music]
all right